foreign
rumors have been swirling that Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott have called it
quits but a source tells E.T the
musician and reality star are on a break
quote the two have had an up and down
relationship and although they aren't
together right now it doesn't mean it's
over for good The Source adds that the
Kylie Cosmetics founder and the rapper
live different Lifestyles and that's
been a big issue quote with two kids
Kylie doesn't go out too much Travis on
the other hand lives a life of late
nights in the studio and going out with
friends
of course the two share a four-year-old
daughter stormy and an 11 month old son
whose name they have yet to reveal baby
number two congratulations thank you so
do we have a name no we have some um we
have some really strong options but we
haven't officially changed
Kylie and Travis were first linked in
2017 after a brief split in 2019 they
revved things back up in 2020 and have
been together ever since
back in August Kylie shared these loved
up snaps on Instagram alongside the
caption Utopia with you I'm obsessed
with it at the time A source told ET
that things between them were going
super well adding that they have really
mastered being together deep down like I
would love my true fans to know like all
my personal stuff but just two months
later Instagram model Regine Carr posted
this video where she claims she and Trav
were hooking up behind Kylie's back you
had every single girl I know blowing me
up like trav's asking for you to come
back you cheat on that every single
[ __ ] night the whole [ __ ] City
sees it
don't do this Travis denied all that on
his insta story writing quote I don't
know this person I've never been with
this person so please stop with the
continuous cyber games and the fictional
storytelling and while Kylie and Travis
may be on a break now
ET Source says the two love and respect
each other and will continue to
co-parent
[Music]
thank you